what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the seven yonko specifically
ranking them from the weakest to
strongest so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy one piece
videos like this one I want to keep them
coming you know what to do chill parking
within and smash that like button if we
can get 5 000 likes on this one I'll get
started on another ranked video for One
Piece just let me know who you want me
to rank first Admirals Warlords or some
other group make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all first aka the
weakest Janko is buggy I know I know I
will get a lot of hate for this in the
comments no doubt but remember this is
not a popularity poll but a list about
strength AKA who would win in a
one-on-one fight and memes aside buggy
has a lot of strengths like Charisma and
being super lucky but he just hasn't
shown himself to be a strong character
he's arguably the only character on the
list who doesn't deserve to be on the
yonko list at all strength wise at first
when it was an announced that buggy
became a yonko off-screen it was fun to
speculate about how he pulled it off did
he awaken his fruit did he have some big
clash with some yonko or Admirals was he
hiding his true power the whole time but
soon enough it was revealed that his
title as yonko was the result of
misunderstandings and accidents the
poster and news made it seem like buggy
was the leader of the Cross Guild
organization and that he got crocodile
and mihawk who has a bounty of 3.59
billion not that far from shanks's to
work under him not only that buggy was
seen as confident enough to start
putting bounties on the heads of Marines
an amazing idea by the way however when
we catch up to them in the story mihawk
and crocodile are mad threatening to
take Buggy's life buggy looks pretty
pathetic as he's beaten up crying not
even trying to fight back he even offers
to lick the mud off their boots if
they'll spare his miserable life yikes
that's very far from the yonko energy
we've been exposed to so far if mihawk
was seen as the yonko of cross Guild
this list would look different but since
buggy holds the title I had to place him
here on the list ironically though buggy
still got a higher Bounty than Luffy
despite being way weaker at 3.189
billion berries next up we have X yonko
big mom who had an impressive Bounty of
4.388 billion berries she's obviously
strong and I don't need to prove that
she's above buggy I hope I mean it took
awakened law and awakened kid to beat
her and like kaido she's probably not
even dead after all that I still think
it's kind of unfair that she had to face
two opponents while kaido only at the
face one but obviously gear 5 Luffy is
stronger than law and kid so since I
don't have to prove she's stronger than
buggy let's focus on proving she's
weaker than the others in my view kaido
is stronger and he's actually gonna be
the next one on this list so that's
enough for me to put big mom here yes
big mom and kaido Clash for a while
evenly and even split the heavens with
their clashes but it's my belief that
kaido would have won in an extended
fight he had a bigger Bounty which alone
doesn't correlate to just who's stronger
but when combined with the fact that he
was called the world's strongest
creature and the fact that people used
to say if it's a one-on-one fight bet on
kaido I think it all goes together to
suggest that kaido is the stronger one
it's also fitting for Luffy our
protagonist and the man who'd go on to
become a new yonko to go after the
stronger one too so that works well with
the story lastly when kaido thinks of
people that could challenge him he
thinks of Odin Whitebeard Shanks Goldie
Roger and Rox D zebic but tellingly he
doesn't think of big mom suggesting that
he's confident he could beat her for
these Reasons I'm putting big mom here
she definitely deserves respect and her
soul soul food can be tricky especially
if you have fear however so many upper
tier characters even not on yonko's like
kid law and jimbei don't fear her so
it's definitely not enough to put her
higher on this list that's made up of
the cream of the crop next is as I
mentioned kaido also known as the
world's strongest creature remember when
I said bounties aren't all about who's
stronger well I'm bringing that into
play here out of all the living yonko
after whitebeard's death kaido had the
high is Bounty at 4.6111 billion berries
but in my view this doesn't translate to
him being the strongest and you don't
have to look far for the Bounty doesn't
equal power evidence since as I
mentioned buggy has a higher Bounty than
Luffy and he's definitely not stronger
but how could I put the guy called the
strongest creature in the world so low
he has a mythical Zone fruit that lets
him turn into a giant Azure dragon and
his hybrid form is no less impressive as
Zorro mentioned he's like a natural
disaster that can summon tornadoes
slices of wind that cut like swords
lightning and most commonly Flames he
can even surround His dragon body and
Flame so that those who don't have the
advanced ability to admit hockey can't
even attack him without burning
themselves or straight up melting he
even felt like he could take old
whitebeard's life before Shanks made him
turn around however he lost to gear 5
Luffy kaido has been presented as one of
the most Invincible characters one that
couldn't even take his own life no
matter how hard he tried but at the same
time he definitely wasn't presented as
the most unbeatable character in fact we
were told that he lost seven times
before he ever fought Luffy as mentioned
it's also telling that Shanks could make
him turn around and abandon his plan to
take whitebeard's life later when he
thinks of the characters that could
challenge him Shanks and Whitebeard are
present suggesting that he's not as
confident his ability to beat them as he
is in his ability to beat big mom so
then why is his Bounty bigger than
shanks's well I think it's because he's
more unpredictable and not as prone to
remaining low-key Shanks for his part
unless he can't avoid it always tries to
stop the fighting he doesn't feel the
need to show off or prove himself think
about how he didn't even beat up the
petty Bandit that was giving one of the
strongest Parts in the world a tough
time he also stopped kaido the Paramount
War tried to stop Whitebeard from going
after Blackbeard and most recently
stopped green bull he's more like a
peacekeeper and even acts as a goal
between sometimes between the world
government and the pirate world as we
saw when he went to the five Elders to
warn them about a certain pirate the
next one on this list is Luffy and it's
pretty straightforward why I put him
above kaido he beat him in a one-on-one
fight I will acknowledge that kaido did
take damage from many before his Luffy
fight like from Yamato Zoro and the red
scabbards but with kaido's level
durability I don't think that was that
big of a deal to him he could still pull
out his A-game by the time his
one-on-one fight with Luffy started yet
Luffy still bested kaido and it wasn't
just gear 5 AKA his own mythical Zone
Awakening Oda through kaido made it
clear that devil fruit Powers alone
aren't enough to become pirate King
hockey is the key so much so that many
of the strongest characters in the
series like Shanks and the pirate king
Goldie Roger didn't even have devil
fruit Powers it was because Luffy
learned the advanced technique of
emitting his conquerors hockey that he
was able to punch and finish off kaido
even without making contact with his
flaming Dragon form so if Luffy is so
high up on this list why is his Bounty
only 3 billion barriers slower than
buggies and tied with laws and kids
despite the fact that they had the team
up to beat a weaker yonko well it's
pretty obvious the government doesn't
want to put too much focus on Luffy the
new era Joy boy and the living
embodiment of the sun god Nika the
mythical figure that gives hope and
strength to the oppressed of the world
obviously the world government which
thrives on oppressing others fears this
more than anything to the point where
they were more than willing to risk
upsetting kaido if it meant that they
could thwart even the possibility of the
sun god returning this was further
emphasized when the elders were angry
about Luffy's gear 5 form getting
printed on his wanted poster they were
hoping to keep it under wraps not
increasing his Bounty at all would raise
just as much suspicion after what Luffy
did so they tried to spin it like it was
Luffy kid and law who all played an
equal part in taking down the combined
forces of big mom and kaido however I
think we can all agree that in reality
Luffy deserves a higher Bounty than law
and kid and in my view after defeating
kaido and becoming the new Sun God I
feel like his Bounty should be even
higher than kaido's was if the Marines
were being honest about his Threat Level
to that so with Luffy being so
impressive lately how could I put him
below Blackbeard who's next on this list
well let's talk about it Blackbeard has
definitely been a dude to watch over the
course of the series while Luffy failed
to get Ace out of marineford alive
Blackbeard succeeded in taking out
Whitebeard and taking his fruit which is
considered to be the strongest paramecia
now it must be noted that Whitebeard was
old sick and already heavily injured but
it's still impressive what Blackbeard
accomplished compared to luffia
marineford he even got to add a number
of dangerous and Powerful impel down
prisoners to his crew while Luffy was
training he beat Marco and his forces
and got proclaimed ayanko replacing
Whitebeard and gaining a bounty of
2.2476 billion berries the reason I'm
comparing Blackbeard to Luffy is because
Blackbeard is being set up as Luffy's
major antagonist Luffy the Sun God who
wants freedom for all facing off against
the more Machiavellian dark dark fruit
using Blackbeard Sun vs Darkness there's
no doubt that these two will eventually
Clash but they're really into
interesting part here is that we've been
following Blackbeard's rise in the
pirate world just like we've been
following Luffy's we've sort of seen
Blackbeard start from the bottom like
Luffy and make it all this way and
whereas Luffy tends to not overthink
things Blackbeard is a master planner
with a scary amount of patience he
waited so long to get the dark dark
fruit and all the while he stayed in
whitebeard's Shadow even though he was
strong enough to be a commander even
before he ate the fruits had to be the
most dangerous fruit power in the
history of all devil fruit Powers he
purposely refused the position not
wanting to attract attention to himself
most recently in the manga we saw him go
after former warlord boa Hancock's
especially tricky devil fruit in the
process his crew was turned to stone but
he managed to get his hand on boa and as
we know if Blackbeard is touching you
you can't use your devil fruits Powers
so Blackbeard could have finished off
boa who has an impressive Bounty of
1.659 billion and who is known as the
pirate Empress but it wasn't so simple
if he did boa said that if he wouldn't
be able to restore his crew members even
if he took her food Powers also she says
it is her beauty that makes her power so
effective so it wouldn't be as effective
if Blackbeard just gave it to anybody
still Blackbeard knew that if he let her
go he'd be turned to stone himself so he
was ready to finish her the only reason
he didn't was because the Dark Knight
and right hand of Goldie Roger Rayleigh
showed up and ensured that if he let boa
go he'd guaranteed the return of his
crew at first you might think that
Blackbeard agreed because he feared that
he had no shot against Rayleigh but in
truth he probably wanted his crew back
sure rayleigh's legendary status may
have played a factor but Rayleigh says
himself that at his age he couldn't have
possibly won in a head-to-head fight
against Blackbeard thus even old era
Legends are now praising Blackbeard's
power still you might think that things
finally didn't go Blackbeard's way he
didn't get what he wants when he went
after Ebola he finally came up
empty-handed for once but that's not
what happened he ended up kidnapping
Marine hero Kobe who was also at the
fight and before all of this he already
had a bounty of 3.996 billion very close
to shanks's own Bounty so although Luffy
beat kaido I think Blackbeard still
deserves to be viewed as stronger Beyond
just looking at how stories work and the
fact that Luffy has yet to face
Blackbeard while he's already beaten
kaido we should keep in mind that
Blackbeard has been ahead of Luffy
throughout the story he's not stagnating
but getting stronger all the time just
like Luffy the legendary guy who trained
Luffy during the time skip even admitted
that he couldn't beat Blackbeard Luffy
will eventually fight Blackbeard and win
there's no doubt about that but he
hasn't yet so we can only assume that
Blackbeard is still ahead and thus it
will still be an interesting fight when
they face off against each other however
I still can't put Blackbeard above the
current yonko with the highest Bounty
Shanks shanks's Bounty is
4.0489 billion berries the highest of
all the current yonko but as I mentioned
it would probably be even higher if he
wasn't so low-key and didn't actively
work to keep the p peace whenever
possible I do think that Blackbeard will
eventually surpass Shanks and maybe even
beat him in a fight that is the way the
story is progressing if you ask me
especially with shanks's warning about
him to Whitebeard and the fact that he
got his scars from Blackbeard before
Blackbeard even got fruit Powers however
after what we've seen from Shanks we
just can't put Blackbeard above him yet
and Marine Forge Shanks even asked
Blackbeard if he wanted to challenge him
and Blackbeard pretty much said not yet
knowing he'd lose if he did Shanks did
many notable things that speak to his
power even though we haven't actually
seen him in a serious fight and yes I'm
talking about impressing Whitebeard with
his legendary duel with mihawk splitting
the heavens while clashing with
Whitebeard getting kaido to turn around
at Marine Ford stopping the war because
no Pirates or Marines wanted to mess
with him effortlessly stopping
sakazuki's attack with his sword and
most recently scaring Admiral green bull
Away by just releasing some hockey
because of all this I just can't bring
myself to put Blackbeard above Shanks
even though I think this story will
require Blackbeard's surpassing Shanks
eventually lastly I have Prime
Whitebeard once called the strongest man
in the world and the one closest to one
piece in my opinion putting Prime
Whitebeard here is pretty
straightforward Not only was his Bounty
the biggest at 5.046 billion berries he
was also presented as being the equal of
Roger the pirate king a position above
that of yonko obviously after his rival
Rogers death there is little doubt that
Whitebeard could have gone on to find
the one piece and become the next pirate
king however his Focus was on his family
AKA his crew and not on that title even
though he was old and sick Blackbeard
still needed to use Ace as a pawn in
order to orchestrate the Legend's defeat
yes Blackbeard has the dark dark fruit
and whitebeard's Tremor Tremor fruit
while Whitebeard only had the Tremor
Tremor fruit but as kaido pointed out
fruit powers are way less important than
hockey and we saw how Prime whitebeard's
impressive conquerors hockey clashed
equally with that of Rogers notably I do
think that this era's best fighters have
the potential to surpass Prime
Whitebeard but I just don't think
they're There Yet now channel the pirate
king with it and smash that like button
if you enjoyed this video if we can get
5 000 likes on this one we'll get
started on another ranked video for One
Piece just let me know who you want us
to rank first Admirals Warlords or some
other group if you don't agree with this
list that's totally cool let me know why
in the comments subscribe and hit that
notification Bell if you haven't already
or you will miss future one piece videos
and updates right buggy is clearly the
strongest in the chat if you watch all
the way to this point and also to
confuse those who haven't while you wait
for the next video to drop feel free to
check out my large and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
Admirals a one hour video on Shanks and
much more link to that is in the
description thanks again for watching
and until next time see ya Space Cowboys